und wollen den hier im studio nochmal
vertiefen danke euch sein und das tun
wir mit bild meinung chef philippe
piatti of denn wir sprechen über eine
ankündigung eine forderung die aus wann
württemberg kommt von dem dortigen
finanzminister daniel meyers
frischgebackener finanzminister der will
eine art online schnüffelt plattformen
für steuersünder einführen das haben wir
gerade von kira schon gehört und nun
sagt annalena baerbock ist normal das
zitat von daniel meyers der will damit
sicher und anonym verstöße gegen straf
und steuergesetze melden lassen also
nachbarn auffordern die an nur die
illegale putzfrau zu melden und so
weiter annalena baerbock sagte jetzt
noch keine schlechte idee ja also ich
verstehe nicht warum einer berliner
berbalk das jetzt macht anstatt bürger
aufzufordern dass ihre nachbarn melden
hätte annalena baerbock lieber mal ihre
nebeneinnahmen rechtzeitig selbst
gemeldet also ich halte wirklich
überhaupt nichts von diesem vorstoß vor
allem wofür machen wir das denn alles
für etwas mehr geld im steuertopf im
staatstropf es ist ja nicht so dass
deutschland zu geringe steuereinnahmen
hat und das jetzt die große not ist also
ich meine steuern sind gelebte
solidarität und wenn man sich mal
anschaut wie viel steuern die deutschen
zahlen bürger und unternehmen dann
gehört deutschland zu den solidarischen
gesellschaften auf der welt und das man
jetzt bürger auffordert einander aus zu
schnüffeln und anonym beim start zu
verpetzen das setzt doch die axt an
amanda solidarität die wir täglich
miteinander leben also da fehlt mir
wirklich völlig die fantasie bei wem das
gut ankommen soll was meinst du was
macht als mit uns als gesellschaft also
man muss ja sagen du konntest natürlich
auch vorher bei der steuerverwaltung
schon anonym melden er konnte seine e
mails schreiben oder anrufen oder sogar
auch hin wackeln und sagen ich glaube
mein nachbar der hat eine putzfrau die
er nicht beim fiskus gemeldet hat jetzt
aber dieses onlineportal dass er von den
grünen in baden württemberg ja als
großer fortschritt in sachen
digitalisierung gefeiert wird sie
fördert aber etwas in unserer
gesellschaft
zum beispiel dass man nicht miteinander
ins gespräch kommt dass wir nicht den
dialog geht sondern dass wir eigentlich
ja ein geist in der gesellschaft fördern
ist das heißt wir setzen lieber und das
gehört sich ganz leicht hier im system
eingeben und weg ist es genau also es
ist ja schon möglich wie du es sagst
deswegen verstehe ich nicht warum da ein
junger grüner finanzminister in baden
württemberg an die macht kommt und sich
denkt mein allererstes projekt mein
großer vorstoß meine große kampagne ist
dass sich bürger auffordere einander
beim start zu melden dass es wirklich
ein gesellschaftliches verständnis dass
ich so unangenehm findet das appelliert
einfach an die niedersten menschlichen
instinkte immer es geht auch um
zusammenhalt wir reden seit anderthalb
jahren über zusammenhalt solidarität
füreinander einstehen und das bürger
wirklich einander beobachten sollen
nachbarn kollegen freunde und sich nicht
mehr als mit menschen betrachten sondern
als potenzielle verbrecher finde ich
hochgradig unangenehm wir wollen
natürlich immer wissen von den
kanzlerkandidaten wie sie dann zu
solchen aktuellen debatten zu solchen
aktuellen themen stehen werden gerade
von kira artmann eben gehört annalena
baerbock stürzte im grunde dieses
vorhaben ihres grünen finanzministers in
baden württemberg von daniel baier ist
und du sagst ganz klar kein
gewinnerthema für sie
ich glaube dass es kein gewinnerthema
ist zumindest sehen das auch die
politischen konkurrenten so die union
hat aber auch die spd und die fdp haben
sich massiv davon abgegrenzt weil ja ja
es ist einfach unangenehm menschen
werden aufgefordert einander
auszuspionieren und dann beim start zu
melden also ehrlich gesagt wenn das bei
der grünen wählerschaft gut ankommt dann
mache ich mir doch durchaus sorgen was
mit deutschland passiert wenn die grünen
tatsächlich in der bundesregierung
setzen über entsprechende ministerien
verfügen um solche systeme bundesweit
einzuführen daniel meyers also der
finanzminister in baden württemberg sehr
recht fertig das ja damit dass er ganz
klar sagt steuerhinterziehung ist kein
kavaliersdelikt ich glaube da stimmen
wir alle zu es ist kein kavaliersdelikt
aber die methode die könnte man noch
einmal überdenken wie man dieser ganzen
sache hinterher geht würde absolut wir
sind ja kein korruptes dritte welt land
und uns fehlt an jeder ecke geld das
problem bei den maroden schulen und bei
den gesundheitsämtern die jahrelang noch
mit stift und papier und faxgerät in der
korona krise gearbeitet haben war er
nicht dass wir nicht genug geld hatten
deutschland schwimmt in steuergeld wir
haben das alles deswegen diesen vorstoß
was da jetzt bewirken soll da fehlt mir
einfach das verständnis
[Musik]